200,000 Subscribers.
Thank you.
Hi, YouTube.
Well, that was fast.
At the end of January, I made a video thanking
the first 100,000 subscribers for joining
my channel, and now, just three months later,
the subscribers have been doubled, which is
an unbelievable rate of growth, so thank you
so much to everyone who's joined up with me
on this little corner of the internet.
These last three months have been a crazy,
busy time for me, with too many projects going
on at once, and the next three months will
probably be the same, with more videos and
other stuff on the way.
One project that's finished now, thanks to
Hank Green, a man who himself runs so many
different things it's hard to keep track of
them all, is CGP grey shirt, which is now
available on the DFTBA store.
In case you're wondering, the proceeds of
the shirt will be used to purchase coffee,
that coffee will fuel the typing and clicking
needed to manufacture videos, videos which
may contain links to buy the very shirt that
brought them into existence, thus completing
the circle of life.
So, go grab one today if you'd like to support
the channel.
It's been amazing making videos for you, while
watching the channel grow, though now releasing
each video to so many people is slightly intimidating.
Even though I take far, far too long researching
each one, I still spend the first few minutes
after uploading living in fear that I've made
some unintentional error and waiting for the
inevitable comment pointing out where I made
a typo, and there are always typos.
But, terror of errors aside, the nice thing
about having such a large community is being
able to share not only my own stuff with you,
but also other people's videos, either through
hidden links on my own, or in separate playlists,
like the one I made this week.
Though, on these videos, I've noticed people
often leave comments like, Grey's army coming
through, and I'm not sure an army is the best
representation of who we are.
I'm more a science and technology guy who
likes reason and simple things that turn complex
in interesting ways, and since you're here
watching these videos, I assume you are as
well.
I'm not sure what the best collective noun
for this growing community is, but if you
have any thoughts, I'd love to hear them.
Anyway, I'm getting off topic.
You are the reason I can continue to make
these videos.
Thank you for watching, and thank you for
subscribing.